what's going on guys this is Rob and
before we start this video I just want
to give a huge shout out to Derek over
at Sony's social media team I thank you
so much for for a discovery my channel
and for reaching out give me this
opportunity it was amazing it was an
absolute amazing experience if you're
ever looking to reach him to like to
come up a community on YouTube hit me up
and I would love to you know do more of
these press junkets for coming up with
movies how many said that for those of
you guys who are interested in like the
experience and how awesome Derek was and
what it was like to interview Tom Hardy
and all that stuff then Jurgis Tom Hardy
and and in Riz Ahmed then like go over
to my vlogging channel I'll have the
link down in the description you got to
be able to check it out and see what the
whole interview process was like and how
bad I was freaking out and everything so
anyway guys let's let's go into the
interview so here's my question is this
is really exciting to me this movie is
Sony's outing into the Sony Cinematic
Universe is this political is this gonna
be a political it is not it is not
political okay all right this is the
routing into the Sony Cinematic Universe
my question is is there pressure here
there's always pressure in these movies
but it's nothing to do is like Sony
blessing I mean but loyalty is to
thinking about the fans and they're
making sure that they're pleased with
this portrayal because venom has been
around for such a long time be around
even off to a gun and it's like you know
we're gonna do it justice so that's the
pressure at least in my mind yeah it's
gonna be proposed like pressure to evoke
dynamicism you know and I think with
people who are passionate about what
they do you need something to push
against in order to to go out and try to
do something and then people like rays
and Michelle Rubin and you know
creatives and artists that we working
with everybody he didn't come to just
you know like like take a paycheck and
just like you know the dial or phone
something in we want to play you know
and the pressure is there also because
Venom's much-loved character that
belongs to a lot of people and they want
specificity and we are under that back
and all that cost of going well you know
you've got to turn out results that's
Buchan
you can't just go or you know I'm gonna
be a slave to to the fear of that
pressure you otherwise you wouldn't we
wouldn't be doing what we don't do it
kid I mean suppose okay it's there it's
the elephant in the room but the same
time this so much the mine here
so much fun here and so much to be had
here and there were so many ways of
interpreting and playing with this and
that progresses in the natural evolution
of this character so you know yes there
is pressure but at the same time it's
it's almost like the stick that pokes
you to leap and on jump and and
hopefully the net will appear and if not
you won't know because I mean it's it's
I like that you guys said that because
I'm sitting here thinking and off the
back to that last question
you guys are hugely successful actors
like multiple award-winning actors so
you guys have played the gamut of like
different kinds of roles and different
projects and my question is what's it
like going from like warrior for example
or like four lines what's it like going
from a project that there goes from that
level to something that's more tied into
like you know superheroes comic books
geek culture
I love full lines what's it like
transitioning from those more indie
movies to these ones there's a couple of
practical differences one is that the
indie movies shoot in a much more
concentrated space of time so it's more
like a sprint these are a bit more like
a marathon also the fact you got more
time means that they usually try out
lots of different versions of it like
will do one version of the scene and
then next week we might try and reshoot
it and do a different version of it and
then they do reshoot
so that means you have to be a bit more
flexible and be willing to go anywhere
with it whereas with the more
independent movies that you're doing a
short space of time like you've got go
with your car you make a decision you
get you've got two takes and you move on
you don't have as much time optimal II
you want to get that essence into a
bigger budget movie if you can
encapsulate that that which is the five
dollar performance into a 50 million or
five hundred billion dollar world then
you're capturing that you're capturing
the nub of what's important about the
world here that's the essential element
we're trying to critically attach
ourselves to gender mean and so there's
no there's no difference between a five
dollar performance in a 50-million but
working the the the working condition is
the difference well the variables will
change due to the size challenges both
ways where this challenge is both ways
if you go like four weeks to shoot a
movie the challenge is man I would have
really loved to have had a third tank
and if you've got like 15 takes then the
challenge is okay we got to try and
preserve that same like Spartan we had
on one take two
so for me anyway that's what I find is a
bigger difference is like the working
conditions are different but they're
it's not like one's better than the
other they're just different skills you
know sprint muscles and marathon muscles
I think personally I think yeah well I
mean final question for me what was your
favorite scene to film
oh there seems to aren't in this movie
there are like 3040 minutes worth of
scenes that on in this movie your
favorite like the mad puppeteer in
scenes like duck comedy scenes to the
mean that just never made it you know
like there are just people that's for me
for me in terms of you enjoyed filming
them they did making film is probably
they weren't any good bro I'd hate to
break it to you you had a meeting we
watched a we liked its home enjoyed
making so much but it wasn't like plays
on my face hello darkness my old friend
what was your favorite scene alright
it was the scene that we did where we
attack together together and and you
were much much better than me well I've
taken up enough of your time
so I appreciate it yes you never did
explain the comment